the yearly speech where Hong Kong's
leader outlines future policies for the
territory was in peril before it even
began and the heckling continued in the
chamber lawmakers please be silent
anyone who does not stay silent will be
asked to leave the chamber president of
legco dear lawmakers dear fellow
citizens pro-democracy lawmakers
projected the slogan 5 demands not one
less on the chambers walls
these include universal suffrage and an
independent inquiry into police violence
during demonstrations Carrie Lam did not
address any of these demands at all
in dramatic scenes miss Lam abandoned
the planned speech she later gave her
address via videolink
dramatic moments there I'm joined now by
Tanya Chan she's a legislative counselor
in Hong Kong and was one of the
pro-democracy lawmakers disrupting
Carrie Lam speech Tania Chan thanks so
much for joining us at DW quits with so
much upheaval in Hong Kong for months
now
was your disruption inside the
legislature the best way to get Carrie
Lam to address your proposals for change
in Hong Kong well this is the first day
an official start of a new logical year
and after all these months our chief
executive mrs. Carrie Lam still refused
to positively answer our demands and
today she wants to deliver her policy
address and without something resolving
the present situation I don't think that
anything can resolve or even can make
Hong Kong to go forward and we have so
many problems laying in front of her but
she decided not to resolve all these
demands but I keep on going and after
looking at his policy address it's just
oh tones and without any innovative
ideas so I really don't know how she can
govern Hong Kong and and at the same
time this is the obligation and a duty
of her legislature to bring the voices
of Hong Kong people jump in there I'd
like to jump in there tell you if I
could
you're saying it's all about resolving
the current situation but the disruption
in a legislature also meant that you
were not able to formally withdraw the
extradition law which would send Chinese
citizens of the Chinese mainland for
trial and that is the sticking point one
of the main ones and and that is isn't
that exactly what your constituents
wants you to do inside the legislature
I'm sure that this is a problem and
should be softer well amongst a
before today and if mrs. Carrie Lam
decided to withdraw the bill at the very
beginning of this movement and I don't
think it will keep on going for so long
and frankly speaking I think the the
pro-establishment cam and mrs. Carrie
Lam are more eager to withdraw the bill
officially instead of us okay do you
think Carrie Lam should resign is that a
good way forward absolutely absolutely I
don't think she can't still govern Hong
Kong and and after all this months we
can clearly see her in capability and so
I think that the very first step for
Hong Kong to go for to go forward eats
her is for her to resign as soon as
possible okay briefly if you could just
a few seconds to go um the US Congress
has voted to impose for a bill upholding
human rights in Hong Kong is that going
to help you do you need more
international help we just have just a
few seconds definitely we need more
international focus we definitely need
more help and please this is
international standard and we want to
uphold our human rights and freedoms in
Hong Kong
well Tania John thank you so very much
for being with us and all the best luck
to you and doing just that thank you